Hello, viewer.
It's the semifinal
and it's Patisserie Week.
I cannot believe I let you style my hair.
There's so much you can do with crème pat.
-Feels quite solid.
-It looks great.
Really? What, floret head?
Welcome to…
[both] …The Great British Baking Show.
-How long's this gonna last?
-Six months.
-Six months?
-Come on, Harpo, let's have a cup of tea.
-[Matt] Now…
-[Janusz] Hello, semifinalists.
-[Matt] …it's Patisserie Week.
-It's about finesse.
[Matt] The bakers face a dainty
but daunting signature…
They're not mini. [laughs]
…a technical turned on its head…
-Don't know how they'll eat this.
-You'd need a very wide mouth.
…and a towering biscuit showstopper.
-[sighs] Stress.
-[Matt] Who will stand tall…
That's not gonna hold.
…and who will collapse under pressure?
[Janusz] Oh, no.
-[Matt] And miss out on a place…
-Bye-bye.
…in the final?
-Oh.
-[gasps] Ooh!
I nearly had a moment there.
[opening theme music playing]
[buzzing]
-[Janusz] How is it four of us?
-[Sandro] Ah, that is crazy.
Semifinal of Bake Off.
Like, this is something
I would have never dreamt of.
[Sandro] It's the most nervous I've been.
I need to get to the finals.
I'm like one step. Too close to leave now.
-Good luck, lovey.
-[Syabira] Good luck, mate.
Today feels different
than every other week
because this is the final push,
and it's pâtisserie, my biggest weakness.
[Syabira] Any little mistakes,
they'll tear you apart
telling you what you've done wrong.
But you just
have to fake it until you bake it.
Good morning, bakers,
and welcome to the semifinal.
Now, for your signature challenge,
the judges would like you each to bake
a batch of six identical mini charlottes.
Your mini charlottes
should have a beautifully-set filling
encased in a sponge of your choice.
I love mini charlottes.
Oh, me too.
Wanna play a game of mini charlottes?
-Yes, please.
-Erm, Charlotte Church, 5'4".
[laughing softly]
-Charlotte from Sex and the City, 5'1".
-Oh. Princess Charlotte, 4'6".
The spider from Charlotte's Web,
16 millimetres.
-Oh. You win.
-Yes!
-You have two and a half hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
[timer beeping]
I have to push myself now.
Semifinals, they're gonna expect a lot.
The pressure is on for sure,
but pressure works with diamonds.
Just feels crazy at the moment
to be part of these amazing bakers.
[Prue] It's Patisserie Week.
For our signature,
we want the bakers
to make mini charlottes.
This is quite tricky.
Mini charlottes should have
a beautiful, very light
golden brown sponge on the outside
with gorgeous mousse or bavarois inside.
The mousse can be any flavour they wish.
Chocolate, vanilla, orange, lime.
[Abdul] Very important I finish this.
I have to make sure that at the end,
I have enough time to decorate.
This is their chance to show off.
We wanna see real artistic flair.
It's gotta look amazing,
like it's in a pâtisserie shop.
We've got four great bakers,
but only three of them are going through
and they have to
really work for that place in the final.
-Look at you in the semifinal.
-Whoo!
-[chuckles]
-[Noel] You made it.
I… I wanna go all the way, though.
-I know.
-I can taste the final.
-You can taste it?
-Yeah.
-What's it taste like?
-Tastes great.
Marzipan.
[Paul] Good morning.
-Hello, Syabira.
-Hello.
How does it feel
coming into the semifinal?
-You've won Star Baker three times now?
-Three times.
Yeah, I did win three times.
It's always a clean slate the next week.
-[Prue chuckles]
-Erm… [chuckles]
Tell us about your mini charlottes.
I am making
cheesecake mini charlotte today.
It's gonna have peanut butter and berries.
Cheesecake.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] Peanut and fruit.
-You wouldn't normally put together.
-It sounds quite strange to me.
[Matt] For her left-field mini charlottes,
Syabira will create
a ring of savoiardi sponge fingers
filled with three layers of cheesecake,
blackberry, strawberry, and peanut butter.
All along,
you've given us unexpected flavours
and they have really worked,
so I don't think you'll fail this time.
So I trust you entirely.
That's the thing
with three Star Baker in a row,
it's just like more and more
being expected, so…
[laughter]
Quite right, we do expect more and more.
It's so stressful.
The first thing I'm making
is the sponge itself
because my whole dessert
will be assembled, er, with the sponge.
[Matt] The bakers' choice of sponge
could make or break their mini charlottes.
[Sandro] So right now,
I'm making the joconde sponge.
It should be like a very, very light,
bendable-without-cracking sponge.
[Matt] It needs to be
robust enough to contain their fillings…
I'm making Polish type of joconde.
So it's gonna be a dry, quite airy sponge.
…while still being light,
delicate, and delicious.
The trick for the ladyfinger
is not to flatten the butter.
If you fold too much, too harsh,
goodbye to ladyfinger.
[Matt] But if making one perfect sponge
wasn't difficult enough…
[Sandro] Today is not the day
to hand-whisk anything.
[Matt] …Sandro's making two.
[Sandro] At the moment,
I'm making joconde sponge
and also doing the banana sponge.
Trying to do that all
within the next half an hour.
So my mum makes this banana cake.
It's coated with caramel
and then it's coated again with peanuts.
Definitely flavours
that remind me of baking with my mum,
so I'm making my version of it.
[Matt] Sandro's turning
his mum's banana cake
into ambitious mini charlottes.
As well as his two sponges,
he'll also pack in two mousses,
peanut and caramel,
along with caramel sauce, praline crumble,
and caramel chocolate ganache.
I mean, I worry about this.
-Will you finish on time?
-Yes.
[Paul] I mean, look at that.
That's taking up half of your bench.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] How many eggs are you using?
-[Sandro] Twenty-four.
-Twenty-four eggs.
'Cause I'm also making pâtisserie cream.
I think I should stop talking.
-[laughs]
-I think we should go away.
[Paul] Unbelievable.
-[Matt] Good luck.
-Thanks.
-Prove him wrong.
-[Sandro laughs] I definitely need it.
[Matt] Meanwhile,
Abdul's taking a less-is-more approach.
I'm going with tiramisu.
It's not too complex.
I kept it simple enough, it's classic.
I rather like the fact
that you've chosen quite a simple idea.
[Abdul] Yes. This is Patisserie Week,
so I need to make sure
I have enough time so I can finish it.
Well, I think you're very sensible
and I hope it works.
[Matt] Abdul will need to
perfectly execute each element
of his simple
tiramisu-inspired mini charlottes
featuring sponge ladyfingers
and pistachio and coffee-flavoured creams.
Have you had a little quiet moment
to reflect on the fact
that you're in the semis?
[Abdul] It's been a roller coaster.
But when you see yourself
having improved so much,
it's kind of awesome to see.
And that's what it's about.
If we pushed ourselves all the time,
we could be Prue Leith.
[Abdul laughs] We-- Yes.
It would be very difficult, but…
[chuckles] I like to push myself.
-I like to push others.
-[laughs]
When they're not looking. [laughing]
[Janusz] All sponge fingers
will be piped now.
With my shaky hands,
so they won't be neat.
I need six of these ladyfinger.
Not doing ladyfingers. Making a joconde
that'll seal all the way around.
Hundred-and-eighty.
So those sponges
will bake for 40 minutes in 170 degree.
So right now, I'm moving on
with my… cream cheese filling.
[Matt] The bakers' choice of flavours
must not only work in harmony…
[Syabira] Who doesn't like peanut butter?
You're probably missing
one of the most wonderful things.
[Matt] …but every element
must be perfectly set too.
[Sandro] This is peanut butter mousse.
There is gelatine.
I pulled back because,
in practice, it was too much gelatine.
[Matt] Get it wrong,
and they could be serving
a sloppy trifle instead.
[Janusz] No one will see.
It's my favourite chocolate mousse.
This mousse
doesn't have any setting agent.
I'm basing my mini charlottes
on my childhood favourite candy,
which is a chocolate plum.
[Matt] Janusz's tribute
to his favourite childhood treat
has plum and dark chocolate mousse
with chocolate joconde sponge fingers
topped with a dome of hazelnut custard.
And he's hoping practice makes perfect.
Have you allowed yourself
to think about getting to the final?
-I went farther than expected.
-Really?
Oh, you will not believe
how much I've exceeded my expectations.
-They were really low.
-Well, how wrong you are.
And yet, we all probably thought
Maxy would still be here.
I've told Maxy, "You'll be the finalist,"
and she said, "Don't be silly."
-I said, "No, you will be."
-You jinxed her!
-You know.
-Evil.
-Syabira, you will be the finalist.
-[both laughing]
[laughing]
Bakers, you are halfway through
your first semifinal challenge.
I've got time. I've got time.
Hello, semifinalists. [chuckling]
Busy. [laughs]
Eighty-seven things
at the same time, of course. Great.
-[Matt] Creating perfect pâtisserie…
-[Janusz] Done.
[Matt] …will test the bakers
to their limit.
So I'm making the mascarpone filling.
I'm then gonna fold it with my caramel.
[Matt] With so many elements to juggle…
Is someone browning some butter?
I smell burning.
…attention to detail is crucial.
Oh, my God,
I've burned my caramel. Sad life.
-[Noel] Hello.
-[Syabira] Hello.
-Semifinal. Enjoying it still?
-I really love baking.
Why don't you enter it again next year?
[laughs] In a disguise.
Oh, cool, of you?
-Come in with a beard…
-[laughs]
…and really high shoes
and call yourself Olaf.
[laughs]
Right, everything
is practically ready to go.
This is the joconde sponge.
You want the ends to meet perfectly.
[Matt] Pâtisserie is all about precision.
[Janusz] I've got a ruler
and everything needs to be
5.5 centimetres.
[Matt] And the judges
will demand consistency across the batch.
[Syabira] Trying to be quick with filling.
I was hoping to set them
in the fridge at least half an hour.
[Sandro] The banana sponge
will be the bottom layer.
It's nice and moist, it tastes nice.
Mini charlottes, Prue.
You have Sandro, who's gone down
about 150 different layers and flavours.
Well, he says he's reined it back,
but Sandro's idea of reining it back
is from, you know, 100 to 95.
[Sandro] This is peanut butter mousse.
Abdul, who's gone down
a more direct route.
Less is more.
[Abdul] Caramel is running behind.
Because there's not a lot of complexity,
I need to make sure each element
has been executed perfectly well.
[Paul] And Janusz,
I like the idea of the plums in there.
It carries such a beautiful flavour.
[Janusz] So, it's half plums,
half chocolate. Hello.
Ah.
Is this a little treat for me?
[Janusz] Oi, don't touch my plums.
[chuckles]
-But then, when you look at Syabira…
-[Prue] Peanuts and fruit cheesecake.
Doesn't sound like my favourite thing.
[Syabira] Peanut butter,
cream cheese first.
She's given us a lot of funny flavours
and they've been wonderful.
[Syabira] Red for strawberry.
Looking for the equal layer.
For Patisserie Week,
a mini charlotte is all about delicacy.
That little bit of finesse
and I want them to step up this week.
[Sandro] I'm not listening to the brief.
It said mini charlottes.
They're not mini. [laughs]
Mmm.
They taste good.
[Syabira] Let it set
for half an hour in the freezer.
[Matt] With their
mini charlottes chilling…
My next task is the flower.
…Syabira and Janusz…
[Janusz] I'm gonna make my custard.
…turn their attention to decoration.
[Sandro] This is caramel ganache.
[Matt] But Sandro's still building layers.
The caramel mousse
is gonna be done shortly.
Still a lot of elements,
but I can get them done.
[Matt] And Abdul has barely begun.
[Abdul] I'll start assembling the layers.
Mascarpone is ready.
So, yeah, it's going to be tight.
[Sandro] That's going
in the freezer straightaway.
It's about finesse.
-[Noel] You wanna be in the Hall of Fame?
-[Janusz] We'll see about that.
-Do you know what happens?
-What?
Someone pulls the lever.
Trapdoor… [whooshes]
You fall down and you get initiated
into a weird ceremony.
Ever seen people on mopeds and they all
get on each other's shoulders?
-Like a human pyramid.
-Yes.
Well, Rahul's at the bottom on a moped,
and you all get into a pyramid.
[laughing]
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
Time is, like, very short, so just gonna,
like, go as quick as possible.
There's a lot of worries, actually,
erm, let me bring out my book
of worries at the moment. [chuckling]
Gonna check my mousse if it's set.
[Sandro] It's nicely set already.
-Ooh!
-[Abdul] I'll put this in the freezer
and just hope for the best.
[Janusz] With the moulding,
the mousse just is about to set now.
[Syabira] Oh! It's not really that set.
[Sandro] This is some cream
with a bit of caramel.
-[Matt] Why are they called charlottes?
-Because Alicia was taken already.
-You think so?
-Mmm-hmm.
-Mini Alicias.
[Abdul] There were
a few decoration elements.
I'll skip the piping, do the chocolate.
Oh, my God. It says I cannot
tie bows without the finger.
[Syabira] How to tie a ribbon?
Can I have someone's finger?
[Syabira] I need a longer ribbon.
-I'll need your finger in the middle.
-Oh, just there?
-[Janusz] Yes.
-[Syabira] Dust them with icing sugar.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
[Sandro] You know what,
I don't wanna tidy up right now. [groans]
[Janusz] Finishing touch.
[Syabira] It's not as perfect
as I wanted it to be.
[Sandro] The hardest bit
is making the bow.
[Janusz] I just want them to look at this
and know straightaway who made this.
[Abdul] Skipped the decorations,
but doesn't matter.
[Sandro] Can't make a bow to save my life.
Can you hold that one?
[Janusz] Yeah, tighter.
[Syabira] And this is the last one.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away
from your mini charlottes.
-Yeah, we did it.
-[Abdul chuckles]
-Let's go and have a coffee.
-Try this.
Mmm. Oh, wow, I like it.
I really hope they don't…
[pops lips] split open.
[Matt] It's time to judge
the bakers' mini charlottes.
-Hi, Sandro.
-Hello.
Sandro, we were asking for finesse.
Do you think you've pulled it off?
I don't know.
Finesse I always associate
with something slightly smaller.
-And it is quite chunky.
-Yeah.
It is a little clumsy,
but it makes your mouth water.
-[Noel] Wow.
-That looks beautiful.
[Paul] We've got all the layers there.
[Prue] Let's see about the taste.
It's all absolutely delicious.
It's just so rich and strong.
Quite overwhelming
with the nuts and everything else,
there's a lot going on here.
All the layers are soft,
but not stodgy, except the peanut one,
-it's a bit gluey.
-That's the only one that had gelatine.
But the sponge on the bottom,
it's really beautiful.
That's some of the best sponge
I've ever eaten,
it's just amazing.
I think I'll take it with me.
Thank you, thank you very much.
Took me all my willpower, not to just go…
-I know, I wanna do that.
-[Noel chuckles]
[exhales deeply]
[Paul] It looks a bit untidy on the side.
This one, the way it's been tied up,
it's broken slightly.
But overall, I think
they're very sweet and pretty.
[Janusz chuckles] A lot of flowers.
[Paul] There is a lot of flowers there.
The plum is nicely set,
but the chocolate certainly isn't,
it's too loose.
You should be able
to cut through it and get a slice.
Flavours are lovely.
Plum and chocolate go well together.
But the joconde is quite tough.
It's much firmer than the middle.
It comes down to the textures.
But the flavour's good.
-[Prue] Well done.
-Thanks.
[Syabira] This is
peanut butter, strawberry,
and blackberry,
cream cheese mini charlottes.
-[Prue] They look really pretty.
-I do love the outside of this.
Quite elegant.
How is this tied up?
-Double knot?
-[Noel] Were you in the Scouts?
[Paul chuckling]
The strawberry cream
is not quite holding its shape.
[Paul] The sponge is delicious, light.
Syabira, you've got excellent flavours.
They're unusual.
I would never have thought
of that combination, and it really works.
But the two creams that you've got
your fruit in, they're not set enough.
That's the issue, 'cause your bottom layer
with the peanut butter is. Thank you.
It's a little bit messy.
It looks like a tiramisu.
[all laughing]
Let's have a look, shall we?
That cuts well.
Mmm.
I think the textures are lovely.
Very, very light.
And I like the fact
that the sponge is light too.
Coffee levels are perfect.
They blend beautifully
with well-set cream.
Inside and flavour, ten out of ten.
The overall look of it?
-[Prue] Not so good.
-Not so good.
Not quite up
to the Patisserie Week standard.
-Yes. Yes.
-You'd be like that.
-This is delicious.
-[laughter]
-Well done. Thanks.
-Thanks.
[Janusz] Saved by flavour.
I need to sit with all of you
and get some decoration tips.
-[Janusz] Dump flowers on it.
-[chuckling]
I'm happy.
At least the insides were great.
They said it's slightly unusual,
but it does go together.
What does it mean by "unusual"?
I think "It's unusual" means a good thing.
Prue said it was
one of her best sponges she's had.
That's my recipe too. Ho-ho.
[Janusz] They liked the look.
They liked the flavours. So 50% there.
Not bad.
Now, it's time for lunch.
[buzzing]
[Matt] The pressure of Patisserie Week
is about to ramp up.
As the bakers once again face the unknown.
Well, bakers, today's technical challenge
has been set by the amazing Prue-dini.
-Any words of advice?
-[Prue] Yes.
Precision is all.
If you aren't precise,
this recipe will not work.
Okay. As ever, the technical challenge
will be judged blind,
so the great Prue-dini
and her beautiful assistant, Pauline,
will now escape the tent.
[Matt] For your technical challenge,
Prue would like you each
to make four identical
chocolate, hazelnut,
and raspberry vertical tarts.
Your vertical tarts
should be made up of crisp rings
of sweet shortcrust pastry
and filled with semicircles
of light chocolate and hazelnut mousse,
and topped with a raspberry jelly.
They need to be identical and elegant,
the sort of thing you'd see
through a pâtisserie window.
Boulangers, you have two hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake.
What the…
I have no idea
what it's supposed to look like.
What?
[Abdul] This will be very challenging,
because this is,
like, beyond me. [laughing]
I hope I could smash it, actually.
Prue, Patisserie Week, vertical tarts.
What on earth are you thinking?
It's the semifinal.
We should be pushing them.
-[Paul] Take us through it.
-It's a really delicate pastry.
It's a shortcrust, but it has ground
almonds in it, so it's really tender.
The chocolate mousse
has whisked meringue in it
to make it a bit mousse-y.
And then when it's set,
decorate it with jelly,
whipped cream, raspberries,
and little tempered chocolate discs.
And gold leaf.
Ah, I thought it was difficult.
[chuckling] So it's not exactly easy.
[Paul] Okay, should we try?
The pastry's got
such a nutty flavour, it's delicious.
That's a really rich mousse, isn't it?
[Paul] Mmm,
and the raspberry's sharp as well.
The trick is the assembly.
If they don't do that carefully
and with precision,
-that's where they'll fall down.
-Yeah, I can see trouble.
I can see trouble in the tent.
First instruction,
"Make pastry and chill."
So I'm weighing all the ingredients.
[Abdul] "Mix the butter and flour
into a crumbly texture."
There's ground almonds.
[Janusz] This is similar to
the French pâte sablée.
It's like shortcrust,
but with a bit of almond there.
I'm just adding in the beaten egg,
it says one to two tablespoons.
Just gonna mix it until it's combined.
-[Sandro gasps]
-Whoa!
-[chuckles]
-[Matt] It gets a bit windy.
-Yeah. [chuckling]
-[Matt] What on earth is a vertical tart?
-We'll have to wait until it's done.
-To know what it is?
-To know--
-Got an image in your mind?
-Nope.
-Wow, now that truly is blind-baking.
[Sandro] I've been first
for two technicals in a row.
I would really like to get a third.
That would be good.
I haven't got a handshake yet, so I'm--
-You've never had a handshake?
-No.
Would you like one from me?
-Meaningless.
-It means a lot to me.
-Kinda need this hand, though.
-Oh, yes, sorry.
Thanks. [laughing]
-The dough now is ready.
-Happy with that.
[Syabira] So this one needs to be
in the fridge, so it's easy to handle.
-Next, "Wash your hands."
-Done, and make the chocolate mousse.
[Syabira] This is
the meringue-type mousse.
I think I remember how to make it.
[Matt] The key to an airy mousse
is gently mixing
the rich chocolate and hazelnut…
That's the praline paste.
That's 50 grams.
…together with the meringue.
But care must be taken.
[Sandro] Fold this bad boy in.
[Matt] Under-mix and it'll be splotched
with egg white.
Hmm.
[Matt] But over-mix,
they'll knock the air out,
and instead of a light, fluffy mousse,
they'll be left
with a heavy, dense ganache.
[Noel] Anything I can do?
Yeah, stay away! [chuckling]
[laughing] "Stay away"?
That's fine. Bye-bye.
Bye, Syabira!
-Bye-bye.
-[laughing]
"Next, line the two eight-centimetre
tart rings with acetate."
Have we got acetate?
Oh… My God.
[chuckles]
I don't know if this is right,
but I'll put the acetate
and cut around it.
[Sandro] "Divide the mixture
between the tart rings. Chill until set."
[Abdul] The mousse is done. I'll chill it.
Now I'm going to move on
to my raspberry jelly.
I'm gonna cook them with sugar
and then add gelatine to them.
I have never made jellies before.
I have made jams.
There's no water in the recipe,
could be a trick.
I think that's not enough liquid.
That's it. No more than that.
And it says, "smooth."
That means I need to sieve them
before I mix them with the gelatine.
That's not a lot of jelly.
I think I've done it right.
[sighs] How I enjoy these technicals.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
"Roll out the pastry
and cut four equal strips."
The butter is melting because
it's really warm, and I'm really warm.
So, there we are.
[Syabira] Has to be thin,
but not too thin.
[Sandro] I wanted to make sure
that these are half-a-centimetre thick,
which is like a, what, pound coin?
So, I rolled the pastries
and I think I rolled it too thin.
'Cause there's quite a few left over.
But it's been done, so…
Why do I have rice?
[Syabira] When you bake the tart,
it has to have something to hold
the crust on the side.
It is important to have that.
I'm gonna bake mine.
Oh, 40 minutes.
No, I don't want 40 minutes.
So, I'm gonna let it bake
for about 20 minutes,
then when I take it out,
it should be crispy and golden.
That's what they're gonna wanna look.
These are so tiny I have no idea
how long to cook them for.
They will not bake for long at all.
Eight, maximum ten.
[Matt] Are you a fan of vertical food?
Not really.
This is the first time I've seen it.
It might look super cool.
I don't know how they will eat this.
-You'd need a very wide mouth.
-Yes.
-Bakers, you have…
-Thirty…
…minutes remaining.
[Abdul] They are falling apart.
Yeah! That's what happened.
Two of them need to be re-rolled.
End of story.
[Abdul] My plan is to put these back in,
and see what happens to these ones,
and then take it from there.
[Janusz] Should have clicked
that there's rice in the drawer,
but I didn't realise, so, there you go.
[Sandro] They're looking
really good actually.
I'm just filling my tarts
with rice so they don't flop on sides.
[Sandro] I like what it looks like.
It looks really clean.
[Abdul] Yeah, they're definitely
gonna break.
[Janusz] They look fully baked.
[Syabira] Yeah, it's cooked.
Need to be careful not to break them.
[Janusz] I've got rice
stuck to them. Great.
These are done.
"To assemble, cut each mousse in half
so that you have four semicircles."
Think I was supposed to line
my shell, like, the acetate, around.
Because that would've
made it easier to get it out.
[Janusz] I'm just gonna
cut my mousse in half.
[Syabira] I hope they fit.
[Abdul] It looks good, it looks good.
[Sandro] That is definitely not a half.
"Place one semicircle
inside a pastry ring."
[Sandro gasps]
[Matt] What happened?
It's just a bit
on the thick side of things.
So, I'm going to just
make it slightly smaller
so it can fit in perfectly
in there with one of these.
-That one!
-That one.
If it's a bit wonky,
it's gonna go that way.
If it's not straight, it's gonna go back.
[Janusz] At least it stands.
[Sandro] That doesn't look nice at all.
"Twelve. Place a strip of jelly
along each cut side of the mousses."
But it is so sticky, so I don't know
what's the best way of doing this.
The jelly didn't set all the way.
Possibly be due to the amount
of water that I added.
I don't know how the hell
I'm gonna put this one on top?
[Sandro] It can't be that.
It cannot be that!
"Place a strip of jelly along!"
I don't know what that fricking means!
"Along each cut side of the mousse."
Each cut side, which will be this side.
But then that's not fitting
and they say it's a strip.
What does "along" mean?
[Syabira] That is actually
the trickiest part of this.
"To assemble, cut each mousse in half."
That way. So, you have…
semicircles.
[knife clatters]
And then it's the cut side.
It goes that way.
Can you tell me how long we've got?
Bakers, ten minutes left.
[sighs]
Honestly, I'm trying to hold
back my tears right now.
[Abdul] It looks good.
They're standing at least.
Please stay.
Can I have my serving plate, please?
To decorate I need double cream.
Doesn't matter how much cream it is.
Shaking.
Okay, that's whipped.
[Abdul] This is so difficult.
[Janusz] This is a really
complicated pâtisserie.
[Sandro] Wow.
[gasps] No!
One of my rings just broke.
If I use the mousse as a glue,
it can be fine.
How are you supposed
to take these in front?
[Sandro] Much better.
I didn't get away with it fully,
but at least it stands, you know?
[Syabira] How many minutes left?
Bakers, one minute left.
[Syabira] Half a raspberry on top.
It's not as shiny as I wanted it to be.
I've never used gold leaf before.
How do you apply it?
Oh. Don't touch it! [chuckles]
Bakers, your time is up.
Bring your bakes down to the table
and place them behind your photographs.
[Abdul] No! Why would you do this to us?
[Matt] Prue and Paul are expecting
four exquisite vertical tarts
with crisp pastry,
luscious light chocolate mousse,
and decoration worthy
of a Parisian pâtisserie.
[Prue] Right, bakers.
-It's quite impressive.
-Yeah, some of them are all right.
Okay, start with this one.
One's fallen down already.
They do look pretty neat.
They're a bit dark,
I think, in places. Overbaked.
That's a ganache. It's no longer a mousse.
Hmm. Mmm. Tastes lovely.
Really hazelnutty.
[Paul] The flavour's good.
But the problem for me is it's too stiff.
[Prue] Okay.
[Paul] This looks very neat.
Good colour. Uniform.
The chocolate's like a ganache.
It's quite delicious though.
If we'd said, "Can you put
ganache inside pastry," it's spot on.
[Prue chuckling] Yes.
These ones are a bit messier.
[Paul] Dear me. Yeah.
The actual pastry itself is very thick.
[Prue] Jelly's not set.
Mmm, the pastry's good,
but it doesn't look good.
[Paul] No, it doesn't look good.
Now, these are slightly underbaked.
[Prue] This is not quite
the precision we're asking for.
But this mousse looks better.
-[Paul] That's more mousse-like.
-[Prue] Mmm.
[Paul] It's underbaked.
You see how soft that is?
[Prue] Oh, yeah.
That's a shame 'cause the chocolate's
actually all right. Wow.
[Matt] Prue and Paul will now rank
the vertical tarts from worst to best.
In fourth spot, we have this one.
Sandro, pastry far too thick.
-And it was a mess.
-Yeah.
In third spot, we have this one.
Janusz, the mousse was the best,
but the pastry was
really underbaked and soft.
In second place, we have this one,
whose is this?
Abdul, slightly overbaked.
The chocolate was a little bit tough.
Which means… Syabira.
The pastry was beautifully neat.
It had the precision we were asking for.
Well done.
[applause]
So, technical,
either I'm first or last. [chuckling]
I mean, given my pastries were
falling apart, second is pretty awesome.
[Sandro] That was confusing.
Really confusing.
My comprehension,
I could work on that a little.
[Janusz] You know,
it's four of us, I was third.
Still sort of middle. [laughing]
But tomorrow will show,
one crack and you're out.
[quacking]
[Matt] Just one challenge remains
before Prue and Paul
decide who will fail to make the final.
[Paul] We've got a situation where
one of the people who have been
pretty consistent throughout is
in a bit of trouble, that's Janusz.
I expect him to bounce
back in the showstopper.
But at the moment, I'd say he was
in the worst position out of the four.
But I think he's not
the only one in trouble.
I think Sandro, his flavours are great,
but he never finishes
and it never looks perfect.
He did a lot of work
in his signature, didn't he?
Yeah, that sometimes
has been his downfall.
[Prue] One I'd really root for is Abdul.
I mean, he hasn't had Star Baker.
He's gone under the radar, hasn't he?
But he's consistently good.
[Paul] Have to say it's Abdul
and Syabira in line for Star Baker,
and it's Janusz and Sandro
in line for going home.
Which is extraordinary to be saying.
-Yeah.
-I hate to say this, but it's all…
[in an old man's voice]
Down to the showstopper!
-[laughter]
-It's all down to the showstopper.
[in normal voice] Bakers, it's time for
your semifinal showstopper challenge.
Now, today the judges
would like you to create your own
visually spectacular take
on the traditional Nordic krokan.
An elaborate,
multi-tiered Swedish pâtisserie
using almond biscuit dough, marzipan,
and featuring icing
and sugar-work decorations.
Now remember, this is your
last chance to impress the judges,
and secure a place in the final,
so don't hold back.
You could just bribe them.
Yeah, Paul's price is 30p
and a small slab of toffee.
[Noel] Whereas Prue, a little more classy…
Wine gums.
[Noel] You have four hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake!
A bit nervous, but…
Push myself, push myself.
There's no space to be worried.
I'm just going to do my best.
[Syabira] Everyone is just so close.
It is very, very skilful person
around me here.
And all lads.
It has to be done for the girls.
Isn't it, Sandro?
Girl power, yeah, yeah.
All about the girl power.
It's the semifinal.
Our showstopper is a krokan.
It's a celebratory Swedish wedding bake.
It's like a wedding cake,
but it's made with very intricate
almond biscuit dough.
Crisp on the outside
and a bit chewy in the middle.
And it is absolutely delicious.
It's almond flavour, of course,
because it's made of almond flour,
but I'm also adding lemon zest
and lemon extract
to get that flavour up and running.
They can do any flavour they like,
but we want it to be tall,
celebratory, elaborate.
A real showstopper.
[Sandro] I'm using at least
six kilograms of ground almonds
and six kilograms of icing sugar,
but that's a lot.
The krokan has to be
a minimum height of 60 centimetres.
So, structurally, it has to be sound.
They've got to get their bake right.
Overbake it, you'll lose that chewiness.
If they underbake it,
it'll be too soft on the outside
and the whole structure
will come tumbling down.
I'm in a bit of panic mode
to make sure that all the dough goes well.
This is the last challenge
before the final. Get this wrong,
they're going home.
-Hi, Sandro.
-[Sandro] Good morning.
-[Prue] Hello.
-Good morning.
Sandro, we need to know about your krokan.
My super-ambitious krokan.
[Paul sighs]
-Is it super ambitious?
-[laughs]
[Sandro] So, this is an ode
to Africa and to the UK.
Where I was born and where I was raised.
It's almost like a thank you
for accepting my mum
all those years back with two kids,
single mum.
If not for that, I wouldn't be here.
-Fantastic.
-That's lovely.
[Matt] Sandro will use
two flavoured doughs,
raspberry and pistachio,
and rhubarb and custard,
to construct his ambitious krokan
featuring Big Ben's clockface,
a map of Africa and the London Eye.
He'll bring his
highly-detailed design to life
with intricate piping, marzipan,
and sugar decorations.
The last couple of weeks, you've been
pushing yourself which is good.
-But you've fallen a bit flat.
-Yeah.
[Paul] Today you've gone down
a very intricate route again.
We wanna see absolute perfection today.
I'm aiming for it.
-Perfection.
-[laughs]
You are one bake away from the final.
-Yeah.
-Good luck.
Thank you. Thank you.
-Use the Force.
-Yes.
[Matt] While Sandro's structure
celebrates his life…
Today I am making double-helix krokan.
…Syabira's is dedicated to life itself.
My specialise is computational biology.
I would analyse data
to understand the human genome.
So my krokan, it is celebrating DNA.
[Matt] She'll create chromosomes
from almond dough
and flavour each of the 50 biscuits
that form her DNA helix
with rose and pistachio.
Decorated with colourful icing
and marzipan,
her towering design will be supported
by nothing more than thin biscuit rods.
[Syabira] It is a quite risky structure.
It has to be perfectly straight
and it has to be
precisely arranged up to the top.
-To keep the balance.
-Keep the balance.
Honestly, it failed
for the first three times I tried.
-Oh, my goodness.
-[Paul] Wow, okay.
But the fourth one stayed standing
for three days, so hopefully…
-Well, good luck.
-Wow.
[Matt] Any hope of assembling
a solid structure
rests on the bakers' ability
to roll and shape
every one of their
biscuit building blocks…
[Syabira] This is a helix.
[Matt] …with pinpoint accuracy.
So it all have to be 14 centimetre long.
[Sandro] This is the raspberry
and pistachio dough.
I'm just making squared bases.
I want to make sure it's precise.
They're all the same thickness.
I'm putting the same amount
of dough in each one.
[Matt] But not all bakers
are rocking the rolling pin.
[Abdul] Gonna pipe my pieces.
I printed these templates
so I can easily follow them.
My plan is to make, like, a rocket ship.
I'm basically celebrating my passion
and humanity's achievement
of getting to space.
[Matt] Full of fresh flavours,
Abdul's ornate rocket will be made
from lemon dough
with orange zest
space-themed marzipan decorations
and he'll add a splash of colour
with sugar stained glass windows.
[whispers] Wow!
Look at the ambition of this.
-Hello, Matt.
-Fantastic shapes.
This requires so much energy.
[Matt] This is your last chance
to impress the judges.
-It is.
-You've been the dark horse here
because you haven't had a handshake
or a Star Baker, have you?
No, I haven't.
This is why I'm like,
"How did I make this far?"
You know, it just feels, er…
You only have to look at what you're doing
to see how you made it.
I mean, look at it.
This is one of the most ambitious things
I've seen since I've come into the tent.
[Abdul] No way. Really?
In that, I would include
Paul Hollywood trying to smile.
[laughing]
[oven beeps]
[Matt] It's the most demanding bake…
Okay.
…the semifinalists have faced so far.
[Abdul] Number one.
That's gonna go in for
about 12 minutes, but I think…
I'll bake these longer
'cause they are the base,
so I do want it to be stronger.
[Syabira] The key is
making the biscuits strong,
but it has to be soft
and gooey still in the middle.
[Matt] But to achieve
the krokan's trademark texture…
The key to the texture
is the right time in the oven.
…they must walk a time
and temperature tightrope.
Gonna switch them around
so they get even colour.
My timer's ending,
but they're still very light.
I might bump up the temperature maybe.
Dude, may I ask
what temperature are you baking at?
I put mine up to 180.
-[oven beeps]
-[Matt] But that's not all.
One out, one in, all the time.
[Matt] Consistency is crucial.
This is the hardest part, batch-baking.
It's gonna be non-stop today.
[Matt] With every biscuit
baked to perfection.
I'm making 19 pieces. It is a lot.
This is just isomalt.
I've decided to make something colourful.
First tier will be a celebration
of the gay flag.
My design is "Brighton Pride."
[Matt] Janusz's three-tiered krokan
is an explosion of colour.
Sitting atop his Pride flag-inspired base
will be pink and blue hearts
as well as black and brown musical notes
to celebrate both the transgender
and Black, Asian,
and minority ethnic communities.
These look great.
Not really pâtisserie,
is it, those colours?
You're in the semis.
You can do what the hell you like.
-[laughing]
-Wanna be in the final, don't you?
Of course I want to be in the final,
but I see the people around me.
[Noel] It's anyone's game.
Just depends on who has a good day.
This looks amazing.
It's as messy as ever
which is a good sign.
It is a very good sign.
-[Noel] Good luck.
-Thank you.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
I would've liked the biscuits to have been
baked within the first two hours.
I've got a lot to do and not much time.
[Syabira] These are chromosomes.
Chromosome is like a bag
that contains all your DNA in it.
If you untangle your genetic structure,
which is your helix,
you will have about
67 billion miles of DNA.
How mad is that?
Krokan, I think this is a really
exquisite challenge for the semifinal.
It's really difficult.
When you think that Syabira
is trying to do the double helix…
[sighs] Don't know how she'll manage that.
[Syabira] The structure itself
is ambitious.
I would admit that, so if I muffed it,
I'm not through for the final.
If Syabira's doesn't fall over,
she could win.
[Paul] This does play
to Syabira's strengths
and also actually Janusz's.
He's building Pride.
The layers have to be
really carefully brought together.
[Janusz] All is good.
All is colourful and pretty.
Once isomalt is in those hearts,
I can start assembling.
-My money's on Abdul.
-[Paul] The rocket.
That looks quite…
It looks amazing, quite spindly.
I'm almost done now.
There's the last pieces.
I just think he's so precise,
organised, and it's a really good idea.
And you got Sandro building
essentially Big Ben with all the bits.
[Prue] I would be surprised
if Sandro finishes though,
because it's so complicated.
I'm sure he'll finish it,
but to what level of finesse?
They keep underestimating me.
I'm being ambitious with it.
I'm going for it, for perfection.
[Matt] Just 90 minutes remain.
[Syabira] Last one.
Should be enough for the entire helix.
Come on sugar, cook.
I'm using caramel
to glue the structure together.
Caramel's really strong.
I have to start assembling.
This is the most nerve-breaking part.
My hands are shaking.
[Sandro] Oh, this one's not meeting.
Ah… [mumbles] Quickly.
That's better.
I am gluing
this main structure together now.
This is gonna be
the central pole of the helix.
It has to be super straight,
so it is how precisely
I can arrange this together
so that it wouldn't fall down.
No room for wonkiness.
[Matt] But while Syabira's, Sandro's…
[Sandro] Africa's sticking just fine.
[Matt] …and Janusz's structures
take shape…
Yep.
…Abdul's still baking.
[Abdul] That's the last one going in.
I'm gonna do my decorations quickly.
I am running behind.
Time, time, time again.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
[sighs] Stress.
Right, these are the chromosome.
[Abdul] I'm making marzipan decoration,
my stars and planets and astronauts,
and then start assembling it.
Oh, it's taking shape?
What's the purpose of this cup here?
[Sandro] It'll hold
what I'm about to put on.
-It's all good. Mmm-hmm.
-[Matt] All good?
Ooh!
-[Sandro] This cup's not great, innit?
-No.
I nearly had a moment there.
[Syabira] I'm doing the double helix.
It's gonna spiral to the top.
I'm just trying to make sure
they're all vertical and straight.
And make sure my caramel doesn't burn.
Make more glue. [exhales]
My eyes are burning.
What a different life
it'd be if you were that tall.
I like your purple gloves.
[both laugh]
You look like a Batman villain.
[giggles] Thank you.
[Abdul] I have the flat edges.
And now it's just time to start
sticking them together.
Seems to be holding really well
at the moment.
[sighs]
[Sandro] This is the London Eye.
It's custard and rhubarb.
That's not gonna hold. It's too weighty.
[Noel] Oh, this is huge.
This is what it's about, right?
I got to do pipework now.
-Pipework.
-Pipework, make the dreams work.
[Noel] Everyone's dug in deep,
is pulling off some business.
[Sandro] I mean,
Janusz's looks like perfection.
-Beautiful, huh?
-Can't see the caramel.
Look at my mess, but I'll hide it.
[Noel] Get in the zone, in the groove.
Got an amazing structure.
Now make it look pretty.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
[Syabira] Nearly there with assembly.
And then move on
with some of the decoration.
My royal icing is Brighton Gin flavoured.
Janusz, I need some help.
[Janusz] I'm coming.
What should I do?
I need to put this on the top.
I'm not sure if it's stable.
-Okay.
-Gonna lift it, and you help.
I'm gonna hold the--
I'm holding the biscuit on the bottom.
Yeah, can you hold it?
-Yeah.
-Crazy Syabira, of course.
I'm just doing some pipework.
Just to add some decor
and definition to some of the bits.
[Abdul] So far so good.
Just the final top bit left now,
then I'll go back to my marzipan,
colour them, stick them.
Finish this, finish this.
[Janusz] My marzipan's falling off.
After I've finished my hearts,
I will get piping.
Every single heart needs
to have a white outline.
[Sandro] That's the isomalt
to bring some colour.
I'm doing blue, white,
and red for the flags.
It's coming together.
I'm trying to cover up the imperfections.
I need to show I can finish things off.
Bakers, you only have five minutes left.
Lots to do, lots to do.
These look an absolute mess though.
[Syabira] This is marzipan
with ground pistachios.
I'm stamping the letters of the DNA.
The code in the genome
contain four different letters,
G, C, T, and A.
-[Noel] You all right?
-Bit stressed.
-[Noel] Got enough time?
-Mmm, doubt it.
I'll do what I can. I'm not giving up.
How long do we have?
You have one minute left.
[breathes deeply]
[Sandro] Isomalt is going on.
Er, blue, where's the blue?
Where's the blue gone?
[sighs] I wish I had royal icing.
[Sandro] That's the red.
Hasn't come out how I wanted it.
This one keeps drooping down.
Okay, bakers, your time is up.
-And breathe.
-[exhales heavily]
-And we can breathe as well now.
-[chuckling] God.
Whoa, man, you pulled off the DNA.
High fives to that.
Look at that, beautiful.
[Syabira] I hope it didn't
fall down though.
No, no, no. Don't say that.
There is more that I could've done,
but I'm happy with how it's turned out.
[object shatters]
[Sandro] My red sugar just fell off.
[Janusz] Oh, no.
[Matt] It's time to judge
the bakers' showstopping krokans.
Abdul, would you bring up
your showstopper, please?
My hands are so sweaty right now.
-Please don't drop that.
-[chuckles]
I think it looks absolutely magnificent.
[chuckles softly]
And I love the little spaceman.
[Paul] It looks great.
You managed to achieve
the symmetry beautifully all the way down.
Got some nice detail in there.
-I love the isomalt windows.
-[Prue] Very clever.
It does feel like vandalism.
-Breaking it up.
-[laughs] Breaking things like that.
[Noel] All that work.
[judges munching]
I think the biscuit's delicious.
It's almond-y, it's chewy,
it's got a good colour.
So all these are marzipan?
These little stars.
[Abdul] Yes, they're all orange marzipan.
[Prue] Mmm.
That's delicious.
Is that made with essence or--
There's orange zest in there,
-as well as some essence.
-Tastes fresh.
That's really nice, that.
Abdul, I think you've done a terrific job.
-Oh, thank you.
-[Prue] Well done.
It's absolutely wonderful.
[Paul] Your design is amazing.
Colours are incredible.
[Prue] And the chromosomes,
are they actually supporting
the whole structure?
-Yes.
-It is just amazing.
[Syabira] I made the base
with almond krokan,
and the top with pistachios krokan.
I think the flavours
are all absolutely spot on.
But the baking varies.
Some of them are a little too dry.
[Paul] The main stand is okay.
It's chewy in the middle.
The pistachio tastes amazing,
almond tastes amazing.
But they're both overbaked.
-[Syabira] Thank you.
-[judges] Thanks.
[whispers] Well done, Syabira.
[whispers] Nicely done.
I think the bottom tier
is beautifully neat, well-executed.
The way you put
the different colours inside,
it really works.
I just think it's slightly untidy
as you go up.
The hearts are pretty even.
But these ones are closer
together than those.
[Paul] Let's see what it tastes like.
Mmm. Delicious flavour.
I want to see if I can taste
the gin in the icing.
Of course you do.
[Prue] Flavours are excellent.
They are a bit overbaked
and not chewy enough.
The best bit I found was just here,
where it's a little bit softer.
But it's lost its crisp. You've gone from
slightly over to slightly under.
And we're trying to look
for something bang in the middle.
I do like it, it's mad.
It's sort of all over the place
like a Monty Python krokan.
[Prue] We have the whole of Africa here.
[Sandro] The whole of Africa.
I did red and blue isomalt
for the UK flag,
but the red isomalt fell off.
It does look as if you've
overdone the caramel.
-Most definitely.
-[Prue] Like it's almost burnt.
[Sandro chuckles]
-[Prue] Mmm.
-[Paul] What's the tang in that?
-[Sandro] Rhubarb and custard.
-[Paul] Mmm. Wow, yeah.
[Sandro] Africa is raspberry
and pistachio.
It's more raspberry than pistachio,
-but the texture's beautiful.
-Okay.
[Paul] Every part
has got a softness to it.
Which is exactly how it should be,
crispy on the outside, soft on the inside.
Chewy with flavour.
It's just a little bit all over the place.
[Sandro] Yeah, I would've wanted it
a bit more finessed,
-especially with being the week it is.
-Well done, Sandro.
[Paul] Thank you, Sandro.
[Sandro] It wasn't as bad
as I thought it would go.
And for once, Paul actually seemed
really impressed with the flavour.
[chuckles softly]
[exhales deeply]
Hopefully, I've done enough
to save myself a place in the finals.
[Janusz] I've got this feeling that
I am, today, in the bottom.
I know that pâtisserie is my weakness,
so it's gonna be a challenging decision.
Which one is going home?
-[Noel] That was an amazing showstopper.
-[Matt] Yeah
All four of them did well.
Syabira's helix looked extraordinary.
[Noel] I mean, that is
an insane idea, right? It's amazing.
[Paul] Problem with that design is
you've got small bits of biscuit,
so it was slightly overbaked.
She won the technical and had
a good signature, didn't she?
Syabira has had a really good
couple of days.
And then the same with Abdul, fantastic.
His textures were all spot on.
It's Syabira or him, isn't it?
For Star Baker.
[Paul] But by very virtue,
we're talking about
Syabira and Abdul for Star Baker,
we are now looking
at Janusz and Sandro to go.
It comes down to little differences.
Can I just say as well,
this is the worst time…
-Yeah.
-…to go home.
-One of them has to.
-Yeah.
-Let's hold hands.
-[Sandro sighs]
[Matt] It's inconceivable to think that
we'll be saying goodbye
to one of you, but we will.
Three of you have made it to the final
and one of you is Star Baker.
And this week, the Star Baker is…
Congratulations, Abdul.
-[Syabira] Yes!
-Thank you, guys.
[applause]
[groans] That means I've got
the horrible, horrible job
of announcing the person who's leaving us,
and this is just the worst time
to go home.
But the person who's leaving us
this week, is…
Janusz.
Doesn't surprise me.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] You did really well.
And Janusz is leaving the tent.
You are a really good baker.
You're not only a good baker,
you're just such a lovely guy.
I am not upset.
The best three bakers are left, clearly.
-[Syabira] I'm gonna miss you so much.
-[Janusz] I know.
It was an amazing time
with amazing people.
Guys, you're the finalists.
Ah, I don't know, man. It's crazy.
It's just crazy. It's in the final,
and then just Star Baker as well,
like, it's unbelievable.
-Well done, mate.
-Thank you.
[Paul] See you in the final.
This is just awesome to see,
because it shows that,
hey, I have been improving,
and this gives me confidence
that I belong with the other two bakers.
-You did so well.
-[Syabira] Thank you.
I'm very happy. It means everything.
It's something that I wouldn't think
that I could achieve.
-Congratulations. That was close.
-Thank you.
Oh, it was.
[exhales deeply]
I'm relieved. I'm happy that
Paul and Prue see something
to be able to hold me
a space for the finals.
[Noel] Congrats.
[Sandro] That's just where
I wanted to get to.
Yeah.
-Aw…
-[Janusz chuckling]
Yeah. Happy tears.
Oh, man.
[closing theme music playing]